Oh actually I see you but not me yeah
see you
oh no I'm called balls hey balls I'd own
bombs Wade you in here listen I'm a
little bit flubber goosed right now well
I'm sure this is gonna be a fun and
relaxing experience and I'm optimistic
it's gonna be great
don't go should i do sandbox there study
with campaign I guess I think price
sandbox is best just for the first one
so that we can yeah I go down I guess
and yeah I put captain way down on my
jobs list I do not wanna be I'm just
gonna random preferences and I don't I
don't know what I'm just gonna do mark
you might do that too
why do I gotta be captain cuz then it's
your fault do you guys care which
submarine the beryllium Barilla the
dugong the humpback give me that one
sounds like us a former military vessel
the wh4 le humpback has been outfitted
to withstand most of the dangers in deep
Europa oh yeah that's right we are not
on earth we're not outside the solar
system we are diving in one of Jupiter's
moons that is primarily made of water
Europa it's like spooky need to go
deeper yeah we're gonna be humpback
let's do this boys ride waiting waiting
for round to start all right he would
goooo I oh oh hey oh my god I'm
wibbly-wobbly guys arms are all signed
oh no all of these things are touchable
oh member capacitor sweet hacking Jesus
hi how you doing Wade coil gun loader
yeah the coil gun loader you know
railgun loader yeah I'm making us move
I'm making us move I'm doing my mating
[Laughter]
let me get over here for a real quick
for
why is the first thing we do every time
we play a stupid game come to the gun
deck wait you can jump pelvic-thrust
your way out of the ballas my god that
was amazing at the same time we're like
[Laughter]
the action [ __ ] is happening
please God serenade us oh snap yeah
what's up now [ __ ] oh wait it's really
getting down to it I'm so down to it oh
I came in damn it damn it mark I am
jamming oh yeah jam on cranly jamming oh
yeah I am do you like the world
hide my thighs in my spine yes save you
mark how do I get rid of the Scott who's
gonna turn that blue wire I got orange
wire I got screwdriver
I got ranch so I turn up the recharge
rates from zero okay oh the power zero
but the load is 1933 that's okay
I found our problem we have no oxygen
tanks in this oxygen distributor is that
bad yeah maybe
keep it together soldier you know what
the power was off oh hey guys I turn on
our nuclear oh oh hey this armor in here
and [ __ ] everything you need for a good
time sure yeah I got fuel rods over here
that's probably good
oh I got plasma cutter and crowbar oh
that's probably good all right I got
stuff
with it Margarida embassies doors not a
door was opened wide we're underwater no
I couldn't let me Oh God
passive sonar Oh insufficient power oh
we make more power not gonna lie mark
I've been trying to use handcuffs on you
for like 30 seconds and I can't figure
it out listen I'm very glad that you
can't I'm gonna take this diving mask
hey wait how many of those hang on just
in case sorry more busine a highly
potent neurotoxin that's that's an anti
rad and so foreign my little bar went
away now I've got some suffering from
the medical god stop don't worry guys
everything
come on guys I think we did it badly I'm
gonna max out our fusion our fishing
raid
all right cool good good the problem is
there's no oxygen tanks in the oxygen
thing wait wait do you mind freeing me
from this prison no wait um um right Oh
fire there's fire bodies what is this
[ __ ] I may have made a nuclear reactor
fire it's okay unbind me away from the
reactor you idiot okay Austin there has
to be a way get away from the locker you
idiot
Oh goddamn it five right here I
literally can't how would I do this you
know this is what you deserve for trying
to lock me Oh guys I found a room where
there's water okay can I sink the ship
don't know why would you do that it is
wet in here why why can't I turn you off
automatic this is for cloud oh it's a
mask oh my gosh up or down
are you oh by the guitar okay I'm coming
okay yeah let me see if I can figure
this stop why are you what are you where
are you going get away from things that
are actually and right here what just
happened
I don't know apparently I'm the captain
by the way so I don't know that's about
Oh what the [ __ ] I'm on a light what's
up douche bag oh my god uh-huh wait I
got it I got it I got it I got it
boom you're free oh thank you you're
free my farms Oh
oh sweet when did you get here I'm glad
I'm grabbing your penis alright let's
have a party boys I'm just gonna rap do
with me what your well daddy's let's
figure out how to get the chip okay okay
insufficient power that's our progress
in this thing grab the periscope you
look outside yeah this says insufficient
power so we gotta get power have some
how
well the batteries upstairs were all off
nothing I set them to charge it's all
from the reactor the reactor needs to be
it's off right now okay your skills may
be insufficient to use the item
electrical engineering level 30 required
I can do the reactor you need me to
power up the reactor yeah let's get this
bad boy going all right I'm gonna put it
on auto it has an automatic control
thing so I'm just gonna put on auto I
think having a grenade will be good God
Wade you say the most worrying good I
look I got squeaky shoes all right you
guys ready to go oh wow okay I'm setting
the autopilot on what we're moving
you're driving started changing the
ballasted Wade was wait either go up or
down get off of there close the door so
it doesn't flood the holes goddamn [ __ ]
nothing everyone how are you everything
is obviously not fun you don't scream in
panic for nothing
Marc are you controlling the engine
right now it's on autopilot so if I just
hold full forward thrust that would be
bad okay instructor what in God's name
fabricator
oh there's crafting in this oh dear
diving suit can we get out of here yeah
we can you go outside you can definitely
go outside aha this door is controlled
by buttons or remote
control oh I see okay I'm gonna put on
this mask real quick oh okay interesting
oh god the crap out of me that's it and
then 'we just dropped in it's fine we're
idiots how do you drive the boat I won't
drive the boat it's on autopilot manual
control I don't know that sounds really
risky what I mean it can't be that bad
we're going somewhere and oh no we're
it's broad fine air quality data not
availed this is some really complicated
mark we're gonna actually try to learn
use our brains it's gonna be okay let's
see what we got here really need oxygen
online probably yeah we do Hank water is
rising in here holy [ __ ]
you doing all right bud the pump in the
bottom level is kind of rising up it
might be okay I don't think it is man
no mark this is supposed to be happening
is this you out it was sick it's set to
end it needs to be out right it's
automatic
oh it's automatic never mind that okay
we're good I'm gonna get my I'm gonna
get my wrench out and try and like
repair it okay I'm gonna go back and
look outside okay never mind there's
wait I'm trying to touch myself and I
can't do it oh god why I've got the
bandages and I need to cure my burn your
burn how'd you get burned I walked into
Bob's fire why didn't bomb ever fire
highest Alameda Oh I'm repairing it guys
I'm doing stuff
hey good then good okay it's fully fully
operational balls mechanical engineering
skill increased to 35 hell yes that's
what it does those are the ballasts of a
submarine they're ways or the water
that was pretty apparent but that's okay
yeah that's how we go up and down how we
go up and down buddy
well uh I don't know what I don't know
what my job functions supposed to be you
look like a gunner I think you're the
gunner sweet a lot of it's not gonna be
a lot of work for a gunner under arey
we're in the middle of Europa everything
is gonna be if I shoot you is this team
damage on good oh god don't cry I am the
captain do not shoot me okay what about
this grenade oh god I can't stay up the
mark surface surface or something what
who press something to make that go home
what happened is it suddenly need to be
welded or added or mud it's a monster oh
[ __ ] oh god I'm gonna hop dead oh god
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
alive I've been hurt
gunshot didn't one of you [ __ ] shot
me way did you kill all of us wait I
think so I think it was that monster
Wade literally did that wait you just
started recently hit you once but the
monster look at that monsters help I was
where did the grenade come from the
monster must have brought it a boy oh my
god
yeah we I think we were gonna come back
from that one too it's too bad
hey we made it all the way to the bottom
or something oh maybe not Oh
oh wow yeah please shuttle dispatching
in four minutes it makes you guys
feeling better I died too suffocating we
all died too suffocating because of the
huge [ __ ] hole in the ship yes he
wasn't my fault Lerner now did I help
fix the problem we can respawn in this
submarine I that's currently filled with
water can I just can I just restart vote
okay let's see huh bled to death
okay shotguns make you die not bleed so
that could have been my fault right
right must have been one of the monsters
that was like a baby with its big teeth
it down can't have been that I feel
really good about that I think I'm ready
to go again
all right let's do this over here who's
where hang on I'm coming I'm coming I'm
coming I'm coming I'm come I'm big
middle gun Bob's little front gun wait
how did you get to be the gunner again
that's a good question
I think I'm some kind of an engineer Bob
what are you I am assistant just what
it's sister all right well you're de
facto captain this time I'll I'll get
the systems running boss I got the
automatic no no no I get it I get it
okay well fine then I guess I don't I'm
not needed here what do these mean
Bellis Eleni a and sarpedon Linea what
does that mean I don't know when I hit
one of them they went to I think we got
a do manual control I super don't want
to do that I trust you captain you're my
cat my trust you I I had a pilot active
sonar and
Delaney and Bella's lineage what I've
got selected else Linea Roger that
captain captain permission to go get a
gun just in case some [ __ ] decides to
shoot everyone on ship yeah yeah get one
of those yeah that's probably good
thanks again I'm unauthorized to open
the armory captain oh I got you sir
Percy first guy first buddy Thank You
captain buddy ol buddy ol pal what is it
is the one this one no that's the world
you mentioned this I almost forgot to
get my grenade and my shotgun out and
just looking good cap man just look at
real food I don't I'm locked in right
now why did you lock in here oh you
can't open the door he's just I'm the
only one with permissions to open that
door that's good to know
can I rewire maybe that wasn't I'd mess
with it I probably shouldn't have done
that
I would you how do I put out a fire oh
sure sell the rooms I saw the rooms I
see it I see it I'm a I have full faith
in you sir how do I see outside the ship
oh my driving me my driving thing we're
gonna do shoot me if you out to you
minutes I don't admit it but I don't not
admit it okay I don't think we're moving
we don't even try
you better stay client you'll draw me
three oh we're going boys where we go
wait where we're lucky next time we're
going down boys that guys ready to go
down driving this boat okay all right
cam okay all right okay okay I'm
watching the other gun velocity for
kilometres now are ya what is ready over
a kilometer deep Oh
this guns awesome did you fire it yeah
it was like some fish or something I
killed them so what gun does this wonder
what am I was this gun use yeah am I
good on energy balls helm skill
increased at 13 nice balls hey good job
balls
I think your bottle crashes into the
wall why was bad I see that wall
engines cotton I'm giving her all she's
got me all right we've gotten our daily
quota of Star Trek reference in here
cancel out our moments I'm here for a
minute
that's chiller but chilly goddamn
hacking Out Boy okay I'm gonna make us
I'm gonna descend us at a slower more
controlled rate of death okay all right
so wait you're looking at the bottom of
the ship I'm looking at the top okay
what fish are good and what fish are bad
I'm assuming I'll know the bad ones yeah
they're big they're all right there
there is there is debris
oh no that's tunnels let's we're gonna
slam those brakes on real quick there
uh-huh do you have like sonar that can
tell we're sold coil oh no I have I do
have sonar but it's very much like we
need to go deeper sonar right I'm gonna
pilot us to make sure something didn't I
heard something too left side did you
hear left side when I was like top left
yeah yeah I'm left I'm looking what's
that electrical buzz is there a problem
that's happening like inside I'm not
sure okay
wait switch out for the top gun and keep
an eye up well actually just switch
between them I'm gonna look at the
batteries and the oxygen cuz there was a
bunch of batteries in here I'm just
wondering what they're for That's not me
piloting we both can make contact going
for it getting I'm a wrench it's
efficient power down on power okay Oh
God we're flooded in here I need my mask
putting on a mask okay oh god there's
something here
oh no really I'm dead I don't know what
killed me what the hell is careful in
there oh I was crushed by water pressure
I'm repairing I'm repair Oh
okay I think whoever's the engineer
needs to look at the status I think the
problem was that the engine broke and it
flooded that compartment oh my god you
guys one of those iceberg II things yeah
yeah that was that was after we lost
engine power cuz I had it on autopilot
to maintain position so once the engine
started flooding oh my god oh my god
what were we supposed to do we were too
deep look let's do a mission she's from
yeah let's do a mission I'm gonna do a
cargo mission and see if we can drive a
box from point A to point B okay suits
that we can wear in that pressure oh
that makes sense
yeah all right I'll Drive the boat okay
god I hope is there a map of some sort I
don't know okay medical item transport
all right I'm the engineer yeah I am
captain come on you're the security
officer Wade Marcus the engineer yeah I
think this is a good distribution I'm
okay with being in I'm comfortable with
this so where are these pressure suits
at just so we know there's a cabinet
somewhere that hat so there's diving
masks that the one that I met oh there's
a welding mask mark mark and the supply
cabinet
by-the-bye right here there's a welding
tool in there I've got one I grabbed one
will not protect you from water pressure
right I saw a diving suit somewhere
maybe down I think if you go to the left
and then go down the stairs there's like
a crew supplies it oh yeah here here
what's this aluminum copper steel bar
oh let's jump onto it oh this is for
crafting stuff oh cool dummy ammunition
box handcuffs that's a lot of collecting
wait over here over here diving diving
suits oh [ __ ] oh hello okay so you come
down here whatever we need the suit I
don't think yeah I guess if we explore
oh if you mouse over the diving mask it
has an oxygen tank so the the oxygen
tank on your bar is actually spare it's
like a replacement and so don't equip
the diving mask because you'll start to
use your oxygen
yeah yeah you will that's more ballast
stuff but I think this is regulated
ballast
I think if we wanted to go outside the
ship we would do it right here airlock
oh yeah yeah this isn't that make sense
so we have to close this door anything
yes because if this is the crafting area
then we would be able to gather
resources shove them in this recycler
yeah definitely so we got sonar or
maintaining position so mark you need to
check on the front and rear ballast
pumps the engine and the reactor and
make sure everything's good and in you
it'll tell you what you need to repair
at the wrench or the screwdriver or
whatever but all right so I've got two
more tourer research facilities so we're
moving now okay okay and it's I'm
keeping on the bottom of the ship's
slowly I'll switch between the guns if
you guys are be working on yeah UGI you
just keep an eye on things yes I'll keep
I can help you check too cuz it's on
autopilot I don't need to do too much
I just don't know much I trust that
autopilot it's [ __ ] just twice I guess
it's because we had a boom breech it
last time it was supposed to be
maintaining position I think it only
crashed us into the wall after we were
already getting boned on so how do we
know what is it what depth were safe at
and when we're getting too deep
is there a meter for that somewhere I
think they may have meant that we as
humans were too deep like we shouldn't
have been so basically the engine
failure causes to hit the thing which
caused the breach and that water
pressure killed us but it was fine for
the sub yes all right
Oh make sure you check on the o2 in the
batteries those are probably less
pressing but yeah I'm making some rounds
it's pretty good so far
the autopilot actually seems pretty
legit I'm watching it's maneuvering on
the legation controls it's very it's
very responsible okay everything seems
fine
are we nominal nominal nominal on
Oh there's two ballots there's two front
ballast tanks do they have in the front
do they have separate pumps I know there
was only one pump I actually opened the
door in between the two of them because
I figured that'd just make a bigger buzz
yeah yeah so I don't know if that was a
terrible idea to do but
so that I'm sure it's fine he's fine I
don't know what I'm supposed to be
keeping an eye on so but I'm making
rounds
yeah just make some rounds what's it
seems fine this seems fine
cap I'm curious about something so I'd
do an experiment real quick okay that's
concerning I'm outside the ship cracking
going back in experiment successful
really yeah he did it he did it you did
it
I did it boss all right so lesson
learned it's still pressure I don't know
if it was actually cracked or if it was
just an icon that was like you're in
high-pressure it was just like I had not
gone with crack glass and I was like
that can't be good so it might be I
would have gotten back in yeah probably
so how deep are we right now do we know
didn't it say somewhere I don't see any
information I feel like I saw oh it's on
the can on the helm on the helm it'll
tell me how deep we are
yeah we're 1,000 meters yeah sorry can
we're going we're going much last time I
was basically full speed just like
jamming down we're going up much more
responsible rate right now we're heading
right for a wall kind of it's it's Auto
piloting us some just come home this
seems bad all right I'm in a reverse
course we're scraping it I stopped us I
stopped us all right it's not being such
a worrywart
nice helm skill hey great helm skill Oh
78 boys from the gear icon that seems
like a bad thing right yeah yeah I fixed
that fix that fix that whoa whoa how did
the guns get damaged
no no it's not the guns I see it
upstairs I see wait yeah I'm coming for
it is it this thing or is it up oh
there's a couple of them there's one of
them there's one down and one up what
what where I don't see it uh check every
gun make sure no one's on the ship or
something like that okay oh it's this
thing okay wait
Oh bad things Oh make an electret Oh
what okay I'm fixing this I hear water
running I think we might have a leak
toward the front I think these are just
like electrical overloads I think we do
have a breach in ballast be in the far
right ballast okay for you get on you
get on a diving suit yep and and go into
the farthest right balance yeah yeah I'm
kind of sluggish
I'm not seeing any damage on it we're
all we're sinking yeah it's okay it's
okay I closed it I think so he looked
okay to me it still says there's a
breach and the water levels at 100 I
think it's just because there's a hole
in the ship I'm gonna go outside with a
welding tool and I'm gonna see if I can
do something about it okay I'm gonna put
on maintain position with the autopilot
I am also gonna get a welding tool and
try and come give you an assist with
that okay I'll wait for you then are we
are we getting lava there is orange [ __ ]
flashing up all around me
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh mark can you
open this yank it all right let's go Hey
oh okay alright I'm gonna say I'm not an
expert but that looks like a bad thing
what the lava down oh god oh god no mark
we're sinking into the abyss
okay wait your weight your referee whoa
toss around Oh what's happening I feel
like we should go back inside yeah maybe
we should go I'm the captain I will fix
this okay I'll come with you are we dead
there's blood out there we attacked the
hallmark we need to fix the hold up I'm
gonna bleed to death but here we go I
guess got it fixed it okay oh come back
I'm so dead you have any holes I got a
bandage but I don't think I can do it in
my suit well I've got internal damage to
my body
what happened I may have shot you no no
I don't think you did you shoot me not
well oh my god I have a gunshot wound
why did you shoot Jesus can you save me
wait can you save me wait I'm savable
yeah I can I don't have anything what do
you need a minute come here take the
suit off of me
oh no we're we have another leak on the
bottom oh hey Mark you might wanna see
do you not see the problem why are we
slamming against the ground
happening I don't know mark did you
disappear oh you're down here down below
well I'm drowning
I'm dead we have these suits on alright
yeah well about that well you see the
thing is that I know I'm taking you to
med bay don't
did you just rip in half no you're good
okay Bob I'm a corpse
now you're fine oh this I'm so confused
sociable is happening we it was like our
ballasts were unfeeling and then
immediately slamming full again or
something I don't understand why we're
slamming me broken boxes right now how
do you wait when it come to the helm
come to the helm I have a solution to
this problem is mark okay there he
doesn't look so good no my body you know
it's all to be together I'm gonna solve
all our problems right now but okay oh I
think we could have fixed it from the
inside oh my oh my god it's fine what
what oh my god there's some kind of
problem with what's happening damn it
this is so hard
no it's fine oh yeah I was just
unconscious from the grenade in the
water that I was in I think that was the
autopilot giving us the dick on the
slamming it down but I just don't know
why the autopilot would do that I think
I think it what it was is the engine was
running out of power so I was trying to
go up and then failing and then that
engine would die and then cram all the
way down I think what I need to do is I
need to go and turn some systems down so
they don't use so much power you know
what I'm okay well until the engine was
trying to fight the ballast I think I
may have made a mistake and I told it to
hold position when we were up near the
top and then it was trying to get back
to that hold position right which is not
which so it was trying to climb and then
running out of power and then slamming
against the outside the ship so I
couldn't turn the helm ah
happen no matter where you turn you'll
be right reddit's hey I'm still wet
look at me I'm dripping all right we can
we get some juice my good sir is juicing
up the way captain
I think these junction boxes are what I
was seeing there were two of them broken
on the ship according to the map yeah I
was fixing them don't worry about those
okay tiny problems tiny itty bitty
problems ain't bum bum Hey hi captain
hey how you do nice wow that's a big
night we look at this scary it's really
scary captain this really hey okay hey
this is a plasma cutter oh these are
[ __ ] yeah
hey mark listen buddy hey look at me
look at me look at me yeah you like that
but - but I can't take em off please
unhandcuff me you gotta get some where
the okay
- handcuffs are off how do you do that
you press G to grab them and then their
inventory opens up bottom left and then
you drive it that way by the crotch
thank you okay I have to do this manual
style I am so good understand whoa
you're asking too much of the turbines
oh did I did I boob them yeah yeah you
you can't go that hard cuz our auto
pilot that was full auto pilot oh god
yeah I'm turning on automatic control
cuz yeah you're good oh yeah he really
doesn't like that get it get it
recovered I'll just chill for a minute
is there any way to autopilot like not
autopilot cuz move this thing is unhappy
really did that really suck that much
yeah oh God juice yeah I was watching
this all all manual pilot then I'll just
manual pilot and I'll just take it real
slow okay that's probably for the best
yeah cuz the turbine just went all the
way up to the right and it like suck -
every little bit so are you looking
right now yeah I'm looking right now so
what happens when I go like this okay is
that like a huge spike yeah yeah yeah
okay I'll try not to use I'll stay below
like half throttle I don't actually know
where we're going as part of the problem
the autopilot takes us in the right
direction
I might have to switch to autopilot for
like junctions you something more power
to it so we're not compromising it
I think there's pretty much just how
much power yeah that that thing makes
it's like if I put another fuel rod in
that bad boy it overheats so we only got
so much can't we use the water that's
like around us to coolant earth I could
flood yeah what if you just flood that
whole room with that help making
progress in the right direction and then
we think there's no map ID card I don't
have like a map in my inventory or
anything I wonder if one of the other
ships is like a advanced mapping what is
this white puzzle at the bottom of the
thing look at the oh [ __ ]
sorry I shot okay I was like oh my god
that's it that's just the wall it's just
a background oh it's the background
while I sort of just blindly going down
at this point what you click I may have
shut down the reactor why'd you sit down
the reactor may have shut down the
reactor it's fine yeah I know kidding
okay bring that bring that power is it
damaged so good it seems fine we good
it's coming back online it's just the
fusion needs a little juice in sorry
okay it's okay
turbines back up Oh God wait I'm gonna
try it I'm bill we were seeing some
pretty rapidly all right I think we're
all left okay broken you're coming okay
bottom left where Bob's right here it's
right by the gunnery thing it's right
there this box I see it man that's hard
for me to see okay I don't know why I
see those but that's good just keep me
I'm rumbling is that good when you're
back by the turbines mark let me know
I'm gonna try and see if I can get the
auto pilot to give me a clue on which
direction we need to go okay I'm about
to switch out the fuel rods cuz I think
that might have happened before one of
the fuel rods just got depleted so I'm
gonna make sure you stay on top of that
we are work good for you to do that
right now
I already did it it's done oh that was
quick okay dude I'm good I'm a good
engine we didn't lose power I'm seeing
like an updraft to the right yeah
there's a lot of rocks right above us I
just had a red flash in the top right
the junction compartment we're almost
out of the rough sea so I'm gonna just
floor it a little bit try to get away
from matching
fission rates like hot it was like a one
flash all right all right we can shell
we could shell we can shell okay okay
okay we're morning guys we're doing [ __ ]
like shake really concerning Lee the
left ballast tank is completely empty
and offline right now for me going you
guys are doing so much [ __ ] I'm just
switching between gun uses keep an eye
on when those monsters come I want to
know about it
you are our eyes and our ears with
alright marker you buy yeah yeah I'm no
not yet I gotta repair this thing
downstairs it's overloading for some
reason I don't know why all right I'm
gonna chill with the power consumption
for a minute
I need to use the autopilot to see which
direction we need to go for for a second
you can go ahead and do it I don't think
it's devastating if you do it trust me
there's something approaching from the
top there's something approaching us
Wade leaked leaked leaked leaked where
Oh
whoa God we reach reach up top yeah I
see it
okay it's dead I need a marquee of your
welding gun I got it right now
okay I'm going for it after I had
actually aimed the thing right on it I'm
an idiot but I got a mask on mark you
good I'm fine don't worry about me water
levels going down so we're all right
we're all right we're good we're good
approaching from the top weights like
noon right above us going to the
splashing noise to my left it's fine
it's the water's clearing out it's
self-regulating draining sighs I think I
think we're okay it gets pumping yeah
it's pumping out of the lower thing I
can see the water level so work do you
still see something approaching this bum
no it swam away up straight above us
waiting Oh multiple bogies up I think
it's dead repairing the react yeah fell
off it fell off the radar no it's fine
the engines also need a little bit of
love but I'm gonna okay work on them I
survived guys we did it yeah [ __ ]
miracle
I can't believe it right now I'm so
freakin intense yeah I'm coming I was
just on autopilot and watching and I'm
like oh wait bottomless ship bottom of
the ship you said the balance without a
problem oh you're right it didn't I sure
do
okay repair is dead that one's dead
there should be a leak bottom left
though it was on the gun already I'm
gonna get a welding gun and come help
you mark okay cool oh we can't we can't
we can't we're taking so much water and
I'm going for the other whatever it is I
don't know where it is oh please
Reno
we're good fixed fix holes make sure
we're make sure we're zeroing out with
the water okay I don't know where the
holes are going under yeah I'm gonna
come down with you I need a mask Oh
balls I need one of those as well
there's another in the supply cabinet
down here where is I see the leak
okay patching patching okay it should be
patched in here I gotta go out okay I'm
out
beside so once the leaks are fixed
meetings on that junction box started
running around mark um I'm going for it
okay let me let me go get a wrench or
whatever and see if I can fix it I'm
gonna steal a wrench out of the
engineering cabinet yes like something's
also broken bottom right okay I just
fixed something bottom right so that may
have gotten that no mark whatever this
is is still broken where is it from the
gun it's the it's the helm
okay I'm repairing this junction box
right here okay hey nice engineering
skill upgrade hell to the yeah maybe I
should upgrade some [ __ ] like there
fixed it like that so that way what the
hell is it
don't worry mark downstairs the airlock
is just the airlock has a hull breach
come in that's that's the thing you
climbed down to get out of the bottom of
the ship right right right
okay I think we are it's looking okay
I'm not it just says hull breach for me
so I don't know oh wait I see yeah it's
over here okay I hear water gushing at
the top of this yeah wait is there a
leak got it it was at the top of the
bottom I think I got it was the bottom
here's the bottom I think our good way
what's with the light down here the
lights just flickered horror movie style
no no Joe [ __ ] a horror movie
it says no more hull breach just his
water level 98 but that's fine okay yeah
we're working on it
I can't believe we're not dead God a
miracle here there's been a hole in the
boat there's been several monsters yeah
oh my god just wait till we see the big
ones all right you know what autopilot
you'll lose your privileges can we not
do that what
it's trying to like it's kicking us so
close to the wall to our right
insufficient power I tripped broke I
gotta go for the engine real quick I'm
gonna go see if I can help with the
airlock did you turn it off we're about
to slam we're slamming into the ground
oh god is it doing it again
yeah pilot I don't understand
turning off thrust Oh thrust keeps
sticking to negative 80 maybe it is on
autopilot hang on I'm coming I'm coming
okay that looks better that's looking
way better alright that's looking way
better okay dropping turbine you yeah
yeah yeah I will I will be on the helm
so we don't have that shitty kid turns
out someone needs to be up there oh wait
there are things on the map
oh snap guys I'm a [ __ ] oh okay
okay I understand there's on the edge of
the compass there's a little there's
like little waypoints that give me a
directional heading I still have engine
power so are you in trouble no no
everything seemed fine let me
double-check and just seemed to be stuck
at negative 80 thrust are you going
backwards um I can't can I can't do
anything you can't do anything
let me is this um is this a bug we are
moving backwards I think I just changed
the thrusts maybe down [ __ ] just
happened
engines go and weird turbine outputs
down way down we're like slowly sinking
which it's not great yeah I have no idea
what happened I'm gonna check the
ballasts real quick but the engines
working the end isn't working fine is it
something we might do externally need to
be repaired junction box
wait there's a junction box right here
maybe this is not giving me power to the
to the helm maybe oh there's a bounce
and he's fixing down here the lights are
also like I think it's like emergency
lighting right now did you hit like an
emergency button or something like that
no why is this junction box off wait
what's going on here yeah that Junction
these junction boxes are all off alright
this is off place is off what happened
here oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh my god
get up here oh my god
yeah okay I found the problem holy [ __ ]
that's weird that I got no indicators
for those being broken probably cuz the
the like the systems to alert us to them
was that's true
hey we're still alive okay still an
actual miracle all right I wish there
was a way to check that I feel like I
should have statuses about that or
something on my helm I think the problem
is that I just haven't been going up
there cuz I was like what do I need to
go up there and I'm an idiot turns out I
know I'm trying to help but like I'm
useless it's fine I just find out okay
it's all good okay our velocity is
canceled let's do this boys I better now
okay good good oh Jesus
this is like we need to go deeper except
sort of why I expected it to be when
someone that's described what it was to
me yeah yeah that was like oh god that
sounds terrible a mark the very very
very right balance here baby because
it's preventing us from climbing
engineering skill like trickle engineer
is me baby that's me that's me baby whoo
Wow good work dad a little bit of a hull
breach here oh that's not so good I have
something with that tone of voice you
happen to be speaking in
that's right some flames at the top if
you could not let me know Bob you see
anything on the the radar I'm trying to
keep an eye on literally seeing nothing
which is really concerning well it is
well we have to make up for like 10
minutes we were dropping to the left oh
boy sorry we just kind of go what if we
dropped out the edge of the map or
something just because that would be so
that last that last round when the thing
was body slamming you and me on the
bottom mark [ __ ] submarine you guys
live through that I don't know guys I
can't come true man my King come true by
slam by submersible - oh hell yeah my
home skill is so high guys crushed by a
submarine go to room 3 alright cool
thanks bud hey time here take these
goggles no thanks no the airlock is
still half full of water is there a way
to fix that the airlock yeah I don't I
feel like it should empty itself but
it's it's not it does seem like it would
out of it there's uh there is but I have
to open this door okay I just have to
let it do its work when this doors Wow
okay so that just drains into the ship
and then gets pumped out yeah it's cool
this decent make ascent seriously I'm
not seeing anything on the sonar like
I think we drifted we went down left for
like ten straight minutes there was
below us when I got on the helm there
was stuff at the bottom of the sonar but
then there's been nothing I started
going up and there's nothing I mean
we've only climbed like a couple hundred
meters I guess so it's not like we've
gone that farmer I'm just surprised
there's nothing on the says boat Esha
Mikula breeding grounds four hundred
meters so we're getting close to
something
oh my god yeah that's where we need to
go Oh Bo Bo tesha macula breeding ground
some bodacious boat Asians the grounds
just moti shion's
gotta go watch some breeding junction
box right by me Zell yeah oh this one
down here right by the gun I'm comin
that's right by me screwdriver
I don't know where screwdrivers are I'm
a gunner they're in supply boxes okay
there isn't one in the supply box
immediately adjacent to that okay thrown
a screwdriver on the floor when I was
trying to get one we have a fabricator
and a bunch of stuff can't we just make
a screwin box by meas out again why is
it now why is it different was the one
between me and Bob this time what I just
said everything was quiet and everything
was not being dead Marga why would you
say something why would you even say
something oh no there's a roof above us
there's a roof above us to the left
brochure me Kela greeting grounds to the
leaf I can't go left there's a wall over
there just spent all this time climbing
up next to the wall I don't know what to
tell you but you're going away from the
breeding grounds I know I'm gonna put it
on autopilot and see what it thinks Oh
God okay
hold on my chance here it's only using
full throttle at the moment I would be
the problem with that one okay I'm gonna
go manual control I'm gonna give the
turbine less than what it can do
it's asking for a lot and I'm gonna give
it less is that gonna blow everything up
we'll find out we've survived worse we
slammed our left side wasteland our left
side okay for the engine room I'm gonna
try and slow our descent without like
killing pressure pressure pressure
pressure pressure Oh God Danny's room is
completely flooded I'm going for a
student yeah yeah
okay go coming back at least this rooms
good all right
we're fine come on just turn off the
autopilot it's not on autopilot that way
because the the helm broke in a very
inopportune moment okay okay
okay here we go we're paranoid you all
right yeah all right no no I gotta go
outside we are falling so fast
no I'm fixed I'm slowly slowing our
descent but I don't know if it's gonna
work well the engines were offline so I
don't know how you were
oh wait I'm gonna take it that's like an
updraft over here I'm gonna try and
steer us into the into the outer current
that sounds like a good idea okay stop
telling me the engines are offline it
seems like it's working all right I
don't know what's going on man
I think we're slowing our descent oh
yeah it's gonna be rumbly but I think
this is gonna actually cushion our
descent a lot this is a line up here I
mean that's off line I don't know why
your sub is broken I don't know why good
reference wait the backup power arrays
off backup power excuse me was I just
zapping that's what the batteries are
right yeah wait why is it off online
it's online now I think we're in a
decent position here what lessons did we
learn today
give the turbines less than what they
want bottom line I know I know I know
okay I'm gonna start are we gonna start
moving
can I go yeah go for it man get dropping
no we're good
I want everyone good everyone having a
nice fun relaxing to move at least five
feet no appointment it's been a little
bit too much fun screwdriver wait go
down to the fabricator and see if you
can make yourself a screwdriver to the
wait wait I found a screwdriver I found
the screwdriver that Bob dropped what
about this supply Locker okay there's a
wrench in here I'm gonna give you a
wrench in a screwy okay here I'm
dropping it right here actually I'm not
even gonna drop I'm gonna give it to you
cuz I don't trust you
oh come on man okay nevermind fairly I
dropped it I got it alright I think
we're so close
we're oh no we're 500 meters away okay
oh good that's 100 200 meters away yeah
well we almost just sank so whose fault
is that
ah not mine I don't think I have neither
hurt nor helped this expedition there
appears to be maybe a wall above us the
autopilot is sort of just holding us in
position weird
well there's a wall right above us we're
about to run into one like we're about
to hit it like it's happening right now
right right five four no go left we
can't go up I think we need to go left I
can't see left I can only see up and
there right now is where we just were
where I couldn't get to the thing we
need to get to so I think you need to go
a few feet from hitting that yeah well I
was trying to see if the autopilot would
figure its life out apparently its man
yeah I think autopilot might be
realistic too I just wanted to see what
he had you know show me what you got no
I'm good
he had nothing good I know nothing yeah
what he had was a bag of scrotums
whole bag okay apparently you can we
rewire literally anything in this gaming
yeah I was looking at that and I've
decided that if I touched any of those
things we'd probably lose so I was like
okay all the batteries are real low-key
not the recharging right now well
they're draining they're about to hit
zero so I think is that bad because
we're a pretty tight spot here guys can
you slow down yeah yeah yeah
and I'm gonna tell it to maintain our
position here I gotta go to the end of
this see what's up
templo tell oh that's weird below get
the temp up mark all these recharge
rates are set to 0%
can you change their HR dream yeah I'm
saying I'd put them all at 50 right now
soo that does ya see how the reactors
doing okay reactor it's spiked an output
but it's still okay okay so can I start
piloting again yeah go for it
keep the operational boys all right cap
you got it whatever deliver this
medicine if it kills us which it will I
don't know if it's recharging thing is
actually working no that is the only
reason that we didn't completely lose
power and a couple of those crazy [ __ ]
up situations we had it's recharging is
just recharging very slowly yeah I'm
gonna go down I'm gonna give give the
engine extra juice and that will charge
them back up a bit faster because I
think it right now it's just doing bare
minimum oh [ __ ]
okay that's oh I can't okay problem
we're almost out of fuel cap that's not
what you want to hear like how almost
out of fuel are we maybe like we got
about ten minutes all right well we're a
hundred and fifty meters away from the
breeding grounds and I think I'm on the
right path here what are the odds that
we can limp our way in there without
needing to get fuel how far away are we
did you say we are currently a hundred
and twenty meters and closing in on the
waypoint for the breeding ground jump
ssin box just limp it in there if we can
we do the mission where all you have to
do is drive from one place to another
alright we're closing in on it we are
actually almost at the Waypoint I think
there's something here I think we can
talk with this maybe oh okay I have to
talk close yeah yeah yeah yeah I got it
I got I got it left a little bit left a
little bit not I see it I see it I see
it this is I don't know if you've seen
the interface for driving this thing
Wade but it sucks I can imagine not good
all right we're right below it I'm going
down uncontrollably am i losing power
what's happening whoa whoa
yeah we're good we're good we're good
okay we are almost out of fuel we're not
do we do it we're docked right now Oh
humpback has arrived at viola breeding
grounds gonna lie I hate the sound of
the flowing [ __ ] water in this - yeah
holy [ __ ] it's like they were expecting
a nice 15 minute down the road delivery
like asking for a cup of sugar they
squeak open the door and we're just
drowned and sweat
[Music]